hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner dort
will ich habe es endlich geschafft ich
mache heute meinen lang ersehntes
kitchenaid video
ich hatte euch das ja schon im letzten
jahr versprochen ich glaube oktober
november war die zeit aber da war dann
viel an weihnachten los und ich wollte
einfach auch die ambiente besser
abwarten mein video habt ihr ja schon
gesehen
denn auf der messe gibt es immer wieder
neuheiten auch bei kitchenaid gas
neuheiten
die wollte ich abfahrten habe mir alles
angeschaut und in meinem heutigen video
geht es natürlich um die küchenmaschine
also um die kids day partisan sowie
zudem stadt genannt ich habe immer artig
und gesagt ich glaube beides stimmt ist
egal was ausspricht hofft sommer meinen
die richtige maschine
und am ende des videos gibt es ein
gewinnspiel denn ich habe versprochen
dass ich bei 150 tausend abonnenten eine
küchenmaschine verlosen werde gut ich
habe jetzt fast schon 200.000 abonnenten
das ging relativ schnell
ich habe es einfach nicht geschafft und
es wird eine kitchenette verlost und
zwar wird genau diese hilflos denn das
ist hier nicht meine sondern das ist
eine ganz neue kitchenaid in der kleinen
farbe die ich habe und meine steht jetzt
übrigens grad nicht im hintergrund weil
ich sie ein geschickt habe ich habe fünf
jahre garantie
und bei mir hat sich jeder hebel so
bisher in der spitze locker ich aber
nicht schlimm
bei mir kommt einfach wegen den ganzen
messen und mein mann ist halt nicht so
sorgfältig wird ich zu meiner
kitchenette bin also ich sitze immer auf
dem schoß tragen
und er stellt sein team in den
kofferraum und dann bot der hebel
bisserl locker ich habe kein problem
fünf jahre garantie und ich habs jetzt
eingeschickt und die schützt auch band
wieder da aber jetzt hat er praktisch
die kitchenaid die wird verlost die die
ich jetzt hier stehen hab dich angefasst
habe und das machen wir aber am ende des
videos jetzt vorneweg die fahrer jetzt
euch die kitchen etwa stelle geht schon
jetzt natürlich bei mir in der küche
eine arbeitserleichterung aber man
braucht natürlich keine kitchenaid und
keine andere küchenmaschine um daheim
gesund lecker und toll zu kochen oder zu
packen
das dient wirklich nur zur
arbeitserleichterung bei mir auch zur
zeitersparnis und ich habe mir die
kitchenaid zum beispiel erst mit 24 bzw
25 gekauft von meinem eigenen geld das
heißt auch jetzt gerade an die jüngeren
vielleicht unter euch falls er jetzt
wahrscheinlich das bedürfnis hat auch
diese green machine haben zu wollen
trotzdem wartet lieber noch ein bisschen
spart euch lieber das geld man kann auch
natürlich einfach mit dem handrührgerät
tolle kuchen backen und spart durch das
lieber für später auf denn das ist
wirklich ein objektes sollte man sich
echt nur dank kaufen finde ich wenn man
das geld dazu hat und sich das dann
einfach mal leisten möchte zu für die
arbeitserleichterung wollte ich nur mal
sagen und jetzt kann ich endlich
vorstellen
also jetzt zur maschine die kitchenaid
arte sagen
die besteht aus einem ganz metallgehäuse
sich auch relativ schwer also wenn er
sie mal auf den arm genommen habt dann
wisst ihr dass also die victor zwischen
11 und 13 kilo das ist auch ganz wichtig
denn wenn man da zum beispiel schwere
teige ding drin knetet wie hefeteig oder
nudelteig darf die maschine halt net
sich von der arbeitsplatte runter
bewegen muss deswegen in festen stand
haben und bei der kitchen ältestes
besondere die hatten direktantrieb und
zwar sitzt der motor hier oben in diesem
beweglichen arm mit drin und hat 300
watt und natürlich gibt es maschinen die
haben mehr watt aber das kann man jetzt
mit der kitchenaid nicht vergleichen
denn bei der kitchen ethisch ist so ich
hab halt diese 300 watt direkt hier mit
drin also ich habe hier sowieso nur die
zwei anschlüsse hier oben praktisch für
das zubehör
also hier kann ich das einfach abtrennen
und kandhamal zugehört dran machen wie
zum beispiel nudelmaschine wie gemüse
schneider und ganz viele andere sachen
nehmen noch und kann das hier auch
wieder feststellen
und da sitzen eben die 300 direkt mit
drin deswegen auch direkt an dreht und
ich habe einfach die volle power hiermit
drinnen ganz besondere später kitchenaid
ist eben auch das habe ich auch schon
ganz oft erwähnt das ist dieses
planetarische rührwerk das dreht sich
nämlich in sich selbst und natürlich
auch um gehe um die schüssel herum kann
ich euch einfach mal kurz zeigen
und bei dieser hier ist es so das
besondere an dem rührberg ist eben ich
habe eben dann keine teig reste am rand
das heißt es wird immer alles mit
aufgezogen und alles wird schön
verarbeitet das ist es womit eben warum
ich mir zum beispiel damals auch die
kitchenaid gekauft habe weil ich das
einfach genervt hat an meiner alten
küchenmaschinen dann immer wieder
auszuschalten und unten und xaver zu
hören und das hat man hier halt net
viele sagen jetzt auf doch bei mir ist
trotzdem so das liegt dann einfach daran
dass sie nicht richtig eingestellt ist
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier dem
schneebesen können doch ein anderes sein
gibt es hier einfach dieses teil wo ich
den schneebesen und die anderen elemente
dran machen und es kann höhe verstellen
und zwar geht es einfach mit so einem
schraubenzieher schraubendreher jetzt
demokrat war gerührt und dann kann man
hier
diese schraube verstellen und kann
praktisch dieses element hoch oder
runter bewegen und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal wieder die richtige
einstellung ist übrigens sein herz auch
wie man den schneebesen nämlich richtig
dran macht und andere elemente
ihr habt einfach eine hand hier setzt es
dran und das hat ja hier so eine öffnung
und die öffnung muss halt genau hier an
den stift passen und damit man das match
steht und suchen muss dreht man es
einfach und wenn man merkt dass warstein
kann ich hochdrücken und einfach drehen
und dann haben es praktisch drin als nur
mit einer handbewegung und zwar nehme
ich mir jetzt eine 5 cent münze all das
muss echt ne 5 cent sein also kein euro
stück oder so weil es zwei dann wieder
zu groß die fünf cent münze ist perfekt
die lege ich mir jetzt hier ein stück
natürlich natürlich jenisch also ich
muss jetzt praktisch später dann die
schüssel auswaschen bzw
diejenige die das hat gewinnt und jetzt
schalte ich das gerät mal an auf stufe 1
jetzt hört ihr beziehungsweise seht dass
die münze ständig berührt werde ich das
heißt die einstellung sitzt falsch denn
die einstellung muss so sein dass die
münze nur gelegentlich berührt werden
also hier zu praktischer schneebesen zu
weit unten und ich muss jetzt hier an
der schraube drehen damit dass
schneebesen einfach weiter hoch geht
jetzt komme ich damit gut hin und kam
das material gestaltet selber nicht nach
links oder rechts deswegen aber ich muss
nach links drehen
die zweite hochgeht und das könnt ihr
zuhause aus machen ich habe nämlich echt
schon youtube videos auch gesehen wo
leute die kitchenaid benutzen und die
kratzt an der schüssel also man hört
dass er dann auch und eine kitchenette
darf nicht an der schüssel kratzen und
es darf auch kein teig unten hängen
bleiben dass ich einfach nur eine sache
der richtigen einstellung
jetzt habe ich sie ein stück zu weit
nach links gedreht um euch zu zeigen wie
es aussieht wenn die kitas wenn der
schnee wissen einfach zu hoch sitzt uns
wahrscheinlich jetzt die maschine an und
die münze wird gar nicht berührt und da
kann man eben passieren dass dann euer
teures einfach oben immer raus spritzt
und es darf eben alles passieren
deswegen richtet es noch im kleinen
ticken nach rechts und dann habe ich die
perfekte einstellung und zeigt es euch
einfach noch kurz und jetzt habe ich sie
richtig eingestellt
er hört dass jetzt auch noch mal stufe 1
jetzt wird die münze einfach nur alle
paar umdrehungen mal berührt und das ist
die perfekte einstellung das heißt die
maschine später gewinnt der hat die
perfekt eigentlich steht einfach von zu
hause und wenn ihr die einstellung jetzt
einmal gemacht hat dann gilt die
natürlich auch für alle anderen
schüsseln also auch für meine
glasschüssel zum beispiel auch alle
anderen themen bekommt ihr habt jetzt
übrigens startgemeinschaft ein bisschen
fest drehen müssen
es kann durchaus passieren werden ihr
zum beispiel einen festen teig macht und
teufel nudelteig der wird eine
viertelstunde lang darin geknetet man
kann sein dass sich diese schüssel eben
ziemlich fester reinhard also ihr dürft
auch beim einsetzen der schüssel einfach
nur kurz an drücken und dann einfach
nicht fest drehen wenn er sie fest rät
so wird hier dann braucht ihr echt fast
männer kraft und das dann wieder zu
lösen
aber wenn ihr keinen starken mann zu
hause gehabt und da lieber vorbeugen und
könnte auch zum beispiel bevor ihr
nudelteig macht da unten einfach so ein
bisschen olivenöl einstreichen und dann
löst sich die schüssel immer wieder gut
also das war so ein tipp den ich auf der
messe mitgenommen habe und dächten
das heißt auch alle die jetzt video
anschauen und schon eine kitchenette
haben können jetzt heute ganz viele
tipps noch bei mir bekommen das weiße
hemd sieht es ist standardzubehör also
das gibt es immer bei jeder kitsch nicht
mit dabei das heißt eine schüssel und
diese drei elemente den schneebesen habe
ich ja eben schon gezeigt den
schneebesen benutzt man zb für schnee
oder für sahne also nicht für festere
sachen da verbietet sich macht man auch
nicht nur im schnee den darf man
übrigens nicht in die spülmaschine geben
also die anderen zwei die kann man rein
geben aber ich spüre auch lieber mit der
hand denn das problem ist es besteht aus
alu guss und das würde in der
spülmaschine dann mit dem salz oxidieren
dann wird es so wird es auch schwarz auf
der oberfläche und das ist eben nicht
ganz gut deswegen aber die kann man
einfach kurz im spiel wasser abspülen
so mache ich das auch immer und dann
sind sie auch schnell sauber dann hat
man hier diesen flach hörer den benutzer
zum beispiel für rührt teige oder wenn
man mal zum beispiel
bei der nudelteig einfach will dass sich
die sachen ganz schnell kurz verbinden
nimmt man das auch gerne und kann damit
praktisch festere teige eben verrühren
auch festere krems zum beispiel
und dann gibt es noch den knethaken und
den benutzt man einfach für alle teile
die man gut knetet das heißt für
hefeteig nudelteig vielleicht auch ein
mürbeteig wobei ich mich immer ganz
schnell lieber mit dem mache und es sind
praktisch die drei elemente
jetzt habt ihr hier an der kitchenaid
geschwindigkeitsstufen von 0 bis 10
und die ersten zwei einzeln 2 benutze
ich immer wenn ich einen schweren tag
macht also hefeteig nudelteig webtrekk
kann man gern bisschen kräftiger rühren
da darf man nur die zwei und zwar nicht
weil es die maschine sonst nicht
schaffen würde sondern die maschine die
rührt ja und der teig wird er praktisch
immer gegen die wand geschleudert
praktisch und wenn man da hören kann es
einfach passieren dass die maschine sich
dann irgendwann bewegt obwohl sie so
standfest ist und das war eben nicht so
gut also bei kneten und die wird immer
stufe 1 und 2 und die restlichen stufen
kann man dann eben für alles andere
benutzen also bei stade mache ich es
immer so ich fange dann bei den kleinen
stufen an und geht dann einfach mit der
zeit immer höher
ich zeige mich jetzt einfach mal wie die
kitchenaid funktioniert ich habe jetzt
hier etwas medien etwas gries drin ich
mache jetzt einfach viel schneller
nudelteig und ich finde ja das tolle an
der kitchenaid ist das einfach sehr
einfache ist das heißt ich habe ich ja
eigentlich nur zwei hebel der eine regel
die geschwindigkeit unter andere hebel
mit dem kann ich eben diesen arm hier
betätigen
das heißt die maschine ist so einfach
ich habe keine irgendwie hightech knöpfe
dran sondern habe nur einfach die
geschwindigkeitsregelung und die
einfache bedienung und ich gebe jetzt
einfach noch ein bisschen mit dazu und
olivenöl und schaut einfach mal die
maschine
auf stufe 2
und hier seht ihr jetzt auch wie sie
arbeitet das heißt hier greift sich in
der mitte den teig und geht doch immer
wieder nach außen und holt sich da eben
die zutaten vom rand
ihr werdet jetzt auf gleich sehen je
mehr mails aufnimmt und sie fest weder
datei und dann fängt auch gleich an
dieser kopf hier oben sich zu bewegen
und es ist absolut normal dass er sich
so ein bisschen nach oben bewegt er sich
einfach diese bewegung die er macht mir
nehme ich das nicht machen würde dann
wird nämlich die maschine an sich
wackeln und sich eben von der platte
runter bewegen und deswegen musste eben
da oben ausweiten und einfach diese
bewegung ausgleichen
hier sieht man jetzt ganz gut wie sich
die maschine ist oben bewegt obwohl ich
jetzt auf stufe 2 bin schreibt man
früher einfach damit ihr es noch
gefesselt völlig normal
es bringt ja echt was täglich an hofer
im shop bzw eben e-mails fragen weil
sich einfach viele dann unsicher fühlen
und sich fragen wieso das eben passiert
weil sie sich zum beispiel die maschine
irgendwo mal gekauft haben und einfach
keinen ansprechpartner haben und
deswegen ist auch immer wichtig seine
maschine grad küchenmaschinen das ist
echt ne auch im tor investition muss ich
sagen eine gute investition
deswegen sollte man sich beim
fachhändler kaufen da hat man
ansprechpartner und deswegen arbeite ich
ausschließlich auch immer nur mit
fachhändlern zusammen
die euch dann beraten können und ich bin
natürlich auch zwar immer als
ansprechpartner da aber der fachhändler
kann ich dann natürlich noch immer
genauere details weitergeben
ich habe jetzt den teig gemacht dann
müsste ich jetzt eigentlich noch ein
bisschen länger rühren aber ich möchte
euch auch in dem zusammenhang sagen als
ich so ungefähr ein halbes kilo mehl
benutzt in der maschine kam aber bis zu
einem kilo teig verarbeiten als auch
nudelteig hefeteig und kann bereits ab
einem eiweiß schon praktisch schnee
schlafen
das heißt ich kann mit dem schneebesen
ein eiweiß steif schlagen und es ist
eben auch so die parade-disziplin was
eine gute musik gute küchenmaschine
können sollte dass man eben auch kratzer
kleine mengen machen kann aber eben auch
bis zu ganz großen mengen und bei einem
kilo teig meine ich jetzt nicht ihr
nehmt ein kilo mehl plus die zutaten
sondern er nimmt insgesamt 1
ein kilo teig also praktisch zum
beispiel 800 gramm mehl plus 200 gramm
flüssigkeit und das ist schon ein kilo
also nicht dass sie das verwechselt und
euch dann wundert wieso in kilo mehl
plus ungefähr 500 gramm zutaten dann
eben nicht so gut verrührt werden und
bei der maschine ist es gute die
maschine redet mit euch das heißt wenn
ich sie jetzt anschalte um sie tut sich
schwer
ich höre es dann auch schon gehört und
dann geht das leichter und das ist eben
das tolle was die maschine macht dann
müsste einfach auf die maschine hören
die spricht mit euch auch gerade wenn
man mit euch spricht zeige ich euch noch
mit einem eiweiß wird das steif
geschlagen wird es muss aber an es seien
also nesbitt klein
ich gebe jetzt ein bisschen nach
salzgitter zu damit einmal schneller
geht salzer schüttelt da die
altersstruktur und jetzt auch einfach
immer höher
mit der studie und haben gleich zwei
geschlagene
jetzt habe ich hier den eischnee als ich
mein ist ganz ehrlich das nimmt man zwar
immer so als vorführung ist sich auch
schwierig wenn es wirklich zu klein ist
also dauert extrem lang vier eiweiße
sind viel schneller geschlagen als 1
aber man nimmt also als paradebeispiel
aber es sind echte lebe also ich würde
glaube ich niemals auf die idee kommen
wegen einem eiweiß
wobei ich brauch nie ein eiweiß steif
geschlagen aber mal wieder gutes
trotzdem zu wissen was gemacht
das ist jetzt praktisch so des
standardzubehör was immer dabei ist wie
ich gesagt habe also die schüssel mit
den drei elementen und das ist natürlich
perfekt geeignet um damit zu backen
aber die kitchenaid mit der kammer nicht
nur banken sondern auch eigentlich die
kamera auch nutzen fürs kochen denn es
gibt ganz viel zubehör
ich habe mich auch schon mal ganz viel
gezeigt in meinen anderen videos aber
ich zeige euch trotzdem mal was ich so
an zubehör habt und zwar hat hier zum
beispiel den gemüse schneider
da habe ich so drei trommeln mit dabei
also für grobe und feine rats für
scheiben dann gibt es zum beispiel auch
den fleischwolf mit verschiedenen
aufsätzen da kann man dann auch noch die
habe ich auch gerade dran
für meinen spritzgebäck kann man damit
machen dann gibt es noch die eismaschine
also das habe ich auch letztes jahr
schon mal benutzt
hier habe ich zum beispiel noch meine
nudel walten als nudel walze und
spaghetti schneider und tag lädt alle
schneider ist jetzt so die zutaten die
ich bisher immer hatte es gibt natürlich
noch ganz viel anderes zubehör und
esstisch einfach das tolle man kann
praktisch mit der maschine mitwachsen
und man kann sich zum beispiel immer mal
wieder zum geburtstag oder zu
weihnachten oder zu einem hochzeitstag
immer mal wieder zu wünschen und sich
schenken lassen oder sich einfach selber
beschenken
und zwar habe ich jetzt mit meinem
fachhändler auch im set zusammengestellt
und weiß hat dieses standards hat mit
dabei als schüssel mit den drei
elementen und bei mir gibt es noch eine
zweite schüssel mit dazu allerdings
keine glasschüssel sondern noch eine
metallschüssel denn ich habe zwar eine
glasschüssel und benutzt sie auch
eigentlich immer aber ich benutze im
prinzip nur weil ich hat die videos trio
und ich kann halt da richtig gut durch
filme mit der
marseille dann immer alles schön wie
sich alles vermischt auch am rand zum
beispiel ich persönlich empfehle es aber
nicht so weil das ist schon auch eine
nicht sehr günstig ist ja auch eine hohe
qualität aber ist es trotzdem eine
glasschüssel das heißt wenn ihr zum
beispiel ungeschickte ehemann habt oder
ein kind daheim habt und die schüssel
und wenn die dann halt mal runter fällt
dann hab da halt echt keine schüssel
mehr also das ist so der große nachteil
sich so wirklich wunderschön und sieht
toll aus und wenn es sich so dreht sieht
auch schön aus aber deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich mache lieber noch mehr
zwei eine metallschüssel wird dazu die
sind robust und da passiert nichts und
das ist mit dabei und eine zweite
schüssel empfehle ich euch immer wenn
man braucht immer eine zweite schüssel
beim backen auch beim kochen weil man
einfach immer wieder mal verschiedene
masken macht und ihm stehen der
spülmaschine deswegen dann habe ich noch
mit dabei das ist auch eines meiner
lieblings zubehörteile das ist der flexi
röhrer hier mit dieser gummilippe und
zwar ist der ganz gut auch für festtage
berührt oder wenn ich eine buttercreme
mache und da nimmt einfach komplett am
rand immer alles mit das heißt der schaf
das richtig schön ab und das ist
wirklich eins was ich auch regelmäßig
benutzt und jetzt habe ich mir natürlich
überlegt welches zubehör teil nämlich
dazu und da habe ich mir nicht viele
gedanken gemacht und mich hier für den
food prozessor entschieden und zwar ist
es ein gerät ein zusatzgerät damit
kammer zum beispiel raspeln schneiden
würfeln und das zeige ich euch jetzt
einfach mal kurz und zwar ist es auch
ganz neu auf dem markt ist gibt es noch
nicht in anderen und zwar ist es eben
diese dieser prozessor mit dieser
aufbewahrungsboxen und darf sind einfach
verschiedene scheiben
also ich kann hier zum beispiel diese
scheibe sogar beidseitig benutzen
und zwar habe ich hier feine raspel habe
ich grob raspeln
dann habe ich hier eine scheibe
schneider also für zum beispiel
gurkenscheiben und kann den sommer
individuell verstellen
also für dicke und dünne scheiben dann
habe ich hier diesen würfel der stadt
richtig genial vor allem wenn ich pro
skater machen wir zum beispiel denn ich
kann damit nicht nur hat es gemüse
freien würfeln sondern auch welches
gemüse karotten genauso gut wie tomaten
das ins auge maschine schafft und dann
gibt es hier noch den den kennt meyer so
also den begriff studien sind einfach
stifter also ich kann damit zum beispiel
karotten stifter machen für meinen
leckeren karotten salat und das ist
jetzt noch ein teil das wird noch zum
würfel mit dazu sagen ich baue jetzt
hier vor noch mal dran und zeigt mich
einfach wieder dass diese vorne raus
kommt denn auch sehen also vom
zusammenbau ist ganz einfach man kann da
auch nichts falsch machen also bei
kinetisches so man hat hier immer so
diesen stift der einfachsten muss das
heißt ich kann gar nicht auf die idee
kommen die zahl schon mal zu bauen also
bei dem westen aber zum beispiel bei der
nudeln also bei der nudel walzen könne
es passieren dass aus forschung einsetzt
da muss ich das einfach hier wieder
fixieren und kann vieles wissen wollen
der zusammenbau euch ganz einfach
und zwar habe ich hier einen deckel
schaut auch wegen der reinigung richtig
gut
das heißt ich habe hier einfach so
dieses kunststoffteile und die maschine
an sich das darf natürlich nicht
gewaschen werden steht auch drauf also
nix nix in water und dann stecke ich das
hier rein und jetzt was machen zuerst
bot
und die kann man eigentlich auch nicht
falsch einsetzen denn ich habe hier
praktisch ohne kanten drin
und jetzt habe ich hier schon stimmt da
kommt hier auch mit rein
wer befördert das ganze dann immer nach
unten und jetzt kann ich das einfach
oben draufsetzen und jetzt kann ich hier
den deckel drauf setzen und zwar habe
ich hier so zwei symbole einmal so ein
geöffnetes schloss oder geschlossen das
schloss und jetzt setzt sich das
geöffnete was hier an den ball und kann
dann praktisch zu drehen was jetzt noch
ganz neu ich brauche ein bisschen mehr
kraft aber das geht mit der zeit dann
immer einfacher des hegerings der hebel
da kann ich auch während des dings läuft
erstellen jetzt bei dieser scheibe mit
julien geht's nicht aber zum beispiel
bei den scheiben geht ich dann praktisch
stücke schreiben und dünne scheiben
machen woran jetzt sagst du mir karotten
geben und das tolle an dem prozess ist
ich kann daten eigentlich unbegrenzt
mengen klein schneiden denn das fällt ja
sowieso unten raus
der behälter wird nicht voll sondern und
die schüssel wird voll
ich kann bereits ein viele verrotten
drinnen machen ich könnte aber 20 kilo
karotten machen also je nach dem
richtigen weg ich muss das nicht immer
wieder den mix behälter lernt sondern
ist fällt unten rein und da macht das
jetzt auch so startet einfach mit der
geringen geschwindigkeit stufe und wenn
ihr merkt es sollte schneller gehen
einfach ein bisschen höher fehlen dafür
nichts falsch machen
weil die karosserie nicht auf der großen
gemüse ganz einfach
st
seine studien schöne feine stifte und
die kann ich dann weiter benutzen für
den kartoffelsalat mit karotten salat
oder wenig kartoffel macht habe ich zum
beispiel stehst da mitmachen zeige ich
euch noch die anderen aufsätze
ich habe damals nicht viel also ich
jetzt noch weiteren können dann wäre das
auch noch mit runter arbeitet mal
einfach essen und jetzt setzt sich hier
die zweite scheibe auf also die dich
praktisch beidseitig benutze kann
die löcher sind übrigens für eure finger
gedacht dass man das gut 1 wieder
aussetzen kann und jetzt nehmen wir mal
die großen
einfach business
vermieter heim
macht man nur die halbe ich habe ich
jetzt feine raste sehen zwar ähnlich aus
wie die stifter aber die stifter sind
natürlich gleichmäßiger groß und das
sind eben keine rasten zeige ich euch
noch die groben machte
jetzt nehme ich die scheibe da brauchen
wir den stift übrigens nicht aber das
merkmal sowie hilfseinsätzen es geht
nicht einfach stift raus und da mache
ich jetzt ein paar kaputte scheiben
da haben wir das gleichmäßig sein
und wie gesagt kann ich jetzt hier außen
bestimmen
ich habe fertig
und das sieht man jetzt auch ganz
deutlich also hier dünn dick und es
können da einfach selber bestimmen und
jetzt noch den würfel aufsatz den müsste
her mit denen zwei teilen außeneinsätzen
kann es auch später wieder gut raus
nehmen dann das messer einstecken und
den benutze ich halt gern wenn ich zwei
später machen will mit tomaten oder auch
wenn ich lasagne machen will für mein
ganzes gemüse oder einfach andere
gefahren
mein lieblings aufsatz als ich in fünf
sekunden habe ich gerade zwei karotten
klein gewürfelt und alles hat
gleichmäßig das doch toll
klar später noch einen bauernsalat draus
machen ja das war jetzt praktisch die
sachen und hier zeigt ganz kurz wegen
der reinigung denn da oben bleibt
meistens so dass letztes stück karotte
stecken nämlich das messer weg man gibt
es hier diesen praktischen aufsatz und
damit drücke ich das jetzt einfach noch
durch aber auf jeden fall von der
maschine unternehmen und dann könnte
richtig druck ausüben
und dann habt ihr noch die letzten reste
mit raus das ist jetzt so meins etwas es
ab sofort jetzt wieder so zu kaufen gibt
beim einem fachhändler und zwar die
kitchenaid artist mit den vier elementen
also dem flex führer mit dabei und all
noch eine zweite schüssel nicht die glas
schlüssel sondern auch eine edelstahl
schüssel und als tollen zusatz eben
diesen food prozessor mit dem putt box
und eben den verschiedenen klingelt und
dieser tollen aufbewahrungsbox das
kochbuch kann ich euch auch sehr
empfehlen und zwar gibt es sobald ihr
euch mit eurer kitchenaid einfach weil
kitchenaid registriert da gibt's dann so
eine karte und dann bekommt man das buch
kostenlos zugeschickt und ich finde es
wirklich so ein tolles zeit wir haben
uns viel mühe gegeben auch und haben uns
viele gedanken darüber gemacht und ich
poste euch einfach alle informationen
unten in meiner infobox unter meinem
video bzw
ihr könnt auch einfach alles nachlesen
in meinem shop service - shop.de
jetzt gehört und ganz wichtigen nämlich
zum gewinnspiel und zwar ist im gewinn
enthalten des standardzubehör also hier
diese kitchenaid partisanin himbeereis
in meiner lieblingsfarbe natürlich mit
den drei elementen und wärme setzte
überlegt wie machen wir das gewinnspiel
ich wollte es auch nicht einfach sein
kommentieren und teilen sondern das wird
ein bisschen kreativ ihr dürft mir jetzt
einen kommentar hinterlassen bei youtube
oder facebook
also da müsstet ihr angemeldet sein und
dürfen kreativen kommentar hinterlassen
irgendwas schreiben und der kommentar
der am ende dieser zeit also bis nächste
woche samstag 14
dritter um 23 59 wer da die meisten
likes auf sein kommentar hat der gewinnt
die zu machen wir das also ihr könnt da
entweder ein gedicht verfassen oder ein
witz schreiben oder einen lustigen satz
denkt euch einfach was aus wieso er
unbedingt dieser küchenmaschine gewinnen
wollt wieso ihr die richtige person sei
und ja ich denke es werden ganz viele
lustige sachen zusammen kommen viele
auch kreative sachen da kenne ich jetzt
einfach mal eure gedanken machen und
lässt dann einfach immer wieder durch
ausgeschlossen vom gewinnspiel sind
andere youtuber also dürfen praktisch
nur privatpersonen mitmachen und dann
dürft ihr eure freunde anheuern euch die
likes zu geben und für euch eben
abzustimmen
auf jeden fall müsste dann immer
kommentare durchlese nun auch gerne
andere kommentare licon ja ich denke das
ist ein cooles gewinnspiel könnt alle
mitmachen braucht man kein besonderes
talent dazu sondern einfach nur lustigen
kommentar oder was witziges nein weil
ich kein privates und man deswegen genau
da können doch mitmachen ich drücke euch
allen natürlich die daumen
aber es kann natürlich leider nur einer
gewinnen aber ich denke ja gut es haben
nicht alle was davon hat was davon und
die anderen haben hat jetzt eine coole
anleitung bekommen ja wünsche euch allen
ganz viel spaß beim kommentieren
in zukunft wird es übrigens auch noch
mehrere anleitungen geben also wie man
küche diese maschine benutzt auch andere
küchenmaschine aber die werde ich nicht
hier auf meinem youtube-kanal hochladen
sondern nur in meinem shop
denn meinen youtube-kanal möchte ich so
neutral wie möglich halten das heißt ich
möchte meine rezepte immer noch so
halten dass jeder sie nachmachen kann
egal ob mit oder ohne küchenmaschine
natürlich rühre ich trotzdem meinen teig
in der küchenmaschine und stehen im
schneebesen darf aber alles andere mache
ich ihnen den videos per hand und die
videos witze in zukunft auf einem shop
geben
das heißt wer sich so eine maschine holt
kann dann auch gerne auf einem shop die
anleitung videos dazu eben abrufen und
das finde ich denke ich ganz gut und ich
wünsche euch jetzt noch ganz viel spaß
beim kommentieren und freue mich schon
auf die vielen kommentare und ließ auch
ganz fleißig mit also macht mit die
infos stehen noch mal in der infobox und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wissen
kann ich auch wie kannst du auch wenn
dort die maschine zu streiten
ich mag seinen zauber dass der flecken
drauf hey ich sagte mir echt leid aber
so aus als ich hatte nie so beschreiten
kitchenette liebig hat noch mehr richtig
nein aber ich lass mich da wird die
fläche auf 70 kopieren